How legitimate are meridians and chakras physically and spiritually. So meridians are just
energy pathways that are used by acupuncturists. So an acupuncturist is looking at different
acupuncture points that are along meridians. Now that's different than a chakra. So meridians
are energy points on acupuncturists are on different meridians that are that are energy pathways. Now
it used to be I used to have to say about 25 years ago that they're not measurable, but they are
measurable now. You can actually measure those energy pathways. That is very physical and there's
nothing spiritual about them. So acupuncture is not a spiritual technique. It's not a religious
technique and there's no reason for Christians to not do acupuncture for the spiritual standpoint.
Now it might be a reason to not go to an acupuncturist that's a Buddhist or something like that,
but you don't, but the practice of acupuncture itself is not a spiritual practice.
Chakras are a little controversial because that is a little bit different
and that could be very spiritual. So I don't like to talk about chakras myself,
so I don't discuss chakras and that is not measurable. The one would say, oh you could measure
energy on the chakra. Well, that's really just that specific meridian. So I don't buy into the
chakra thing. I think it's used by new ages and I'm not into that and I think that could be
dangerous from a spiritual perspective. I do believe that as a believer, you could be protected
from all of that and you don't have to worry about those things, but I do think we're supposed to
use wisdom and I don't put ourselves up to practice occultic practice. So I would stay right from that.